welcome back to sunday night in america
president barack obama candidate hillary
clinton and president joe biden all won
the hispanic vote but the margins have
been tightening
a wall street journal poll shows
hispanic voters are evenly split between
the republican and democrat parties
they're tied at 37 percent
so what has changed for years the
so-called experts said the republican
party would be doomed if it did not
support some form of amnesty for those
currently here unlawfully but that does
not happen nothing really has happened
on the immigration front beyond the
reality that it continues to be a
political issue
so what explains the narrowing of the
gap between the parties if this poll is
correct what explains the two parties
now being essentially tied
in the eyes of hispanic voters joining
us now is florida congresswoman maria
salazar it is great to have you back
congresswoman what do you make of this
new data showing the parties essentially
tied
well thank you for the opportunity few
things we share that we hispanics the
browns the latinos in this country the
largest minority in the united states 20
of the population we share the same
values that are entrenched in the
republican party god-fearing law-abiding
tax paying not only that that we are
americans we're not socialists we want
to come to the country and we want to
contribute and what's happening is the
economy remember that phrase from james
carville it's the economy stupid what do
you think we come here for because we
want to contribute because we don't want
it's not that we want to go to disney
world or go shop in saks fifth avenue we
want to come here and contribute we know
that the american exceptionality is
waiting for us
the promised land and the and the
economic policies that were established
in the last administration help
everyone's pocket and i'm so happy that
the new numbers are showing it we are
here because we know that we want to be
republicans and
we have realized that in the last 30
years the political the democratic party
has been playing political football with
us why do i say that because in 2008
president obama promised my community
and immigration reform law within the
first 100 days of his presidency nothing
he invested his political capital in
obamacare number two president biden
said it at the beginning of this year
within the first 100 days of my
presidency i'm going to do an
immigration reform law and what happened
once again he ditched us so now it's
time for the gop to welcome my people
and we will do an immigration reform law
that i'm trying to present god
permitting next
year you know for for the eight years i
was there they would bring in the
so-called immigration experts um
all of whom looked a lot like me and
said you need to do the following things
or else you will never appeal to
hispanic voters and whether rightfully
or wrongfully the republican party
didn't do any of those things so
were the experts wrong or or
what explains this this evolution
within the hispanic community towards
the republican party
what i just said is that we have
realized after 30 years after ronald
reagan who was the last president who
gave this community
some type of legality we have realized
that for 30 years the democratic party
has been playing political football so
what i said to my community is that you
got to be with whomever serves
your values and whomever fixes your
problems we come here for two things we
come because we know this is the
promised land and we want to share those
fruits and we want to have a better
economy we want to be able to go from
rags to riches which is what this
american exceptionality promises i'm the
best example i am the cuban the daughter
of cuban refugees 60 years ago they came
when they were 25 years old to the
promised land because democratic
socialism had destroyed their cube of
their country and look at me i am a
brown girl from the hood with an accent
serving my community on the united
states congress that only happens in the
united states and my people know about
it so i'm so happy we welcome them into
the gop because as i said we share the
same values god fearing law abiding tax
paying we want to contribute and we want
to be welcomed by the gop that so far is
doing a great job and i know that we're
going to continue doing a great job and
what we need to do is we need to send
the message that we want to take care of
those hispanics we're going to seal the
border because we my community we don't
want what's happening the disarray that
we see at the border no we want to be
able to come in legally
contribute and live the american dream
and i am the best example of what that
is i am the american dream we are
americans we're not socialists
well congresswoman i for one wish that
we had had the chance to hear you while
i was there instead of the
so-called political experts who told us
all the other things uh because you make
a very persuasive case for
how to appeal
to hispanic voters and you're right you
have lived the american dream and
we hope that you had a wonderful
christmas and hope that 2022
brings you
something
and let me just say one more thing we
know that unfortunately the democratic
party has been infiltrated by the
democratic socialists that at the end
they are marxist so we are recognizing
from the mexicans to the cubans to the
hondurans to the nicaraguans to the
colombians we recognize what marxism and
socialism means and we do not want that
in the country in the promised land
where we have arrived to and we want to
save our children and future generations
from that ideology so that's another
element that's why we are moving to the
gop
we will give you the last word and we
are delighted that you are in what you
call the promised land hope you have a
great 2022.
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else